what is up everybody its Anna Mac and
welcome to another episode of the week's
best anime videos which is a weekly
newscast about the anime community on
YouTube the links are in the description
recommendations go in the comments one
of the biggest news in the anime
community this week is that the
crunchyroll anime Awards 2016 results
are in and EURion eyes pretty much
dominated the awards and many are saying
that the organised fangirls and fanboys
essentially hijacked the awards this
week both Joey the anime man and Giga
came out with videos talking about the
fact that you realize won six out of 11
awards so far and even though the best
anime award is not going to be handed
out on their jet until January 28th many
are expecting most are expecting I think
that Yuri Anais is going to take down
one as well meaning that Yuri nice is
gonna take seven out of 12 Awards now
think about that think about how many
anime came out in 2016 and you realized
is going to take a majority of the
awards so the awards we're talking about
here include best opening which is
probably justified but then also best
ending best boy best couple and even
best animation yeah because you're a
nice number used repeated sequences to
save money right guys right so what
seems to have happened here is that
essentially the very active Yuri a nice
fanbase decided to vote for Yuri on Ice
in every category because they liked the
show not because they were necessarily
looking at the quality now even you're a
nice fans like our fellow Rand cafe
members simply rolls and Brent from
Brent's fandoms will tell you that while
they like the show they don't think that
you're in I should have won all of those
awards and the problem that's going to
arise now for fans of you realized is
that by voting for Yuri on Ice in all of
these categories even when the show
didn't deserve it they're not going to
face a backlash from the rest of the
anime community instead of raising the
profile of the show and making more
people want to see it it is now going to
be cool to hate on Yuri and ice for
being the most overrated show of 2016 I
think this is an important lesson for
all active fan bases it's totally okay
for you to love a certain show but if
you're gonna put on blinders if you're
gonna put on your fangirl or fanboy
goggles and completely ignore quality
and just vote for your favorite show in
every category because you love it so
much you're going to alienate a lot of
people your show is gonna become
overrated
and if you've lost the anime man and
Google in the anime community that's a
pretty big deal so definitely a lesson
to be learned here Aki dearest made a
video this week in which she asked
whether advertisers were going too far
to appeal to anime fans in this video
Aki showed a few examples of advertisers
using seeds from anime like Dragonball Z
and Sailor Moon and overdubbing the
voices in order to sell you products now
we know that the anime fan base is an
active one and of course advertisers are
going to want to appeal to us but when
you take someone's favorite characters
that they grew up with like Dragon Ball
Z characters and then put words in their
mouth that are trying to sell you
something I feel like most often you're
going to just get a backlash people are
just gonna be angry that you did that to
them
Aki race is a really good point here
when she argues that if you're going to
do ads like this you better make them
good you better make them funny and you
better show the fans that you really
watch the show that you appreciate it
the show that you get the references
that's the only way that people might
actually want to buy your product
otherwise they might just feel like
cheated like they might feel like that
you're putting words in the mouth of the
characters that they love and you might
actually get a backlash Aki actually
just reached 800,000 subscribers on
YouTube which is awesome congratulations
Aki and Joey the anime man also recently
reached 1 million subscribers which is
huge I think also lost paws noble from
lost paws is at 900,000 something so
he's almost at a million so that's
awesome congratulations to all of them
and this is a really good thing for the
anime community on YouTube these big
anime channels are going to raise
awareness of what anime bring new people
into the community which is of course
great news for all anime youtubers and
also for anime fans in general the
future is exciting this past week we
hosted the 8th episode of our rant cafe
anime podcast right here on this channel
and it was a huge success it was the
biggest fan cafe yet we had a special
guest black critic guy who was awesome
thanks Tony we hope to have you back
soon and we also hosted a live stream on
Code Geass in on Saturday at noon so
we're going to be doing these weekly as
well so every Thursday at 5 p.m. Eastern
Standard Time we're going to be hosting
Rand cafe as always and every Saturday
at noon Eastern Standard Time we're
going to be hosting special Code Geass
live streams so we'd love to have you
join us we also have a new video out
here on the channel
about hidden messages in code geass and
whether these are potential clues for
season 3 so if you want to check that
out the link is in the description this
week our friend and rant cafe cast
members simply Rose uploaded a video
about Gianna made the G anime convention
that she will be attending which takes
place in gatineau right beside ottawa on
the border between Ontario and Quebec
the convention is actually taking place
this coming weekend January 20th 21st
and 22nd so if you're in the Ottawa got
no area definitely check it out and the
specific venue where the convention is
going to be taking place is called la
pelea de cornet they got to know see the
eyebrow thing is part of the
pronunciation French is a really
expressive language a YouTube channel
called the Canepa effect released a
anime studio spotlight video this week
about studio trigger now I'm a huge fan
of studio triggers so I really like this
video it's a long video very detailed
but very interesting definitely check
this out and my favorite a MV this week
was a Kuroko no Basuke at last game and
v called love me to death by Kirin AM
V's this is a long run over 4 minutes so
you know it took a lot of work but it is
really well done so be sure to check it
out and that's it for this week thank
you so much for all the support on the
channel recently it means a lot and
until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]